this is GM Daniel naritzki we are
watching one of the great all-time
matchups sikaranakamura against Magnus
Carlson at the 2023 Norway chess Blitz
tournament Magnus Carlson hasn't shown
up at the board just yet a wry Little
Smile by Hikaru and this is a three
minute game so being fashionably late
will bear its consequences but Magnus
does come to the board and still has
time to take his blazer off his clock is
ticking how will he respond to hikaru's
first move already 20 seconds off his
clock but Magnus not too concerned he is
known to play rather quickly in Blitz
chess and still adjusting his pieces 30
seconds now off his clock and D4 is met
with D5 will we see a Queen's Gambit by
Hikaru first he plays Knight F6 no
Bishop to G5 and this is called the Tory
attack Hikaru has played this line
pretty extensively in over the board
Blitz chess particularly at the Norway
chess Blitz tournament it is not
considered a particularly good line but
Hikaru has analyzed it very deeply and
it can be dangerous if black doesn't
respond accurately the knight from FC it
jumped to E4 chasing the bishop back to
F4 and now the position resembles a
London system with that Knight on e4
rather than F6 Carlson taking another
healthy thing here as he pushed to C5
and applied pressure on hikaru's Center
and the bishop comes out to F5 in order
to support the Knight on e4 and we will
likely see a lot of tension in the
center Knight takes E4 probably
inadvisable here because the pawn would
have recaptured and chased the Knight
out of F3 and instead kikaru is playing
this in the style of a London system
playing C3 building up that pawn
triangle and solidifying the pawn on D4
but the other idea is to open up a
pathway for whites Queen which jumps
into B3 and applies pressure on the B7
Pawn that pawn has to be defended and
it's not that easy to defend it well you
don't want to go B6 because it would
weaken the Knight on C6 in fact Bishop
B5
in that position would have likely won
the game on the spot and instead Queen
goes up to D7 now Knight E5 is still a
tempting move for Hikaru but Force the
exchange of knights and Bishop F1 to B5
pinning the queen and the king would be
a major threat but Carlson would have
time to secure the B5 Square by pushing
his ape on up one square now it's
hikaru's turn to take a long thing
trying to figure out a way to generate
problems for black on the queen side he
can bring his Bishop out and he does and
he brings it out to the most aggressive
possible Square Bishop E5 Carlson
immediately responds by trading on D2
Hikaru could take with the King if he
really wants to insist on Knight to E5
and that facial expression seems to
indicate Hikaru is thinking about it and
he does play King takes D2 and of course
the drawback is that the king is now
stuck permanently in the center and in
order to bring it to one side of the
board hikara would have to invest four
or five Tempe Carlson immediately
pushing the pawn up to F6 and covering
the E5 Square keeping the Knight on F3
at Bay and what is hikaru's follow-up
going to be king takes D2 was a fancy
move but it was also a very committal
move a risky move stuck in the center is
the white king and queen to A4 by Hikaru
pressuring the Knight on C6 but Bishop
takes C6 here isn't really a threat that
Knight is well protected by Carlson's
Queen and his Pawn on B7 and we'll see
if black completes his development first
he plays Rook C8 applying even more
defensive power to the Knight on C6 and
an exchange on C5 by Hikaru Pawn takes
C5 is a very typical move in these
structures in order to Garner the the D4
Square for whitesnite and that is why
Carlson first responds by pushing E5 and
taking the D4 Square under control but
the drawback is that the D5 Pawn is now
a weakness and you can see Hikaru
bringing his Rook over to D1 and he is
preparing most likely to drop his King
back to its initial Square King D2 to E1
opening up a direct line of fire by The
Rook to the D5 fun and that is why
Carlson makes a very careful defensive
move as he drops his knight from C6 to
E7 and offers an exchange of queens that
he Karu accepts but the other idea is to
make sure the D5 Pawn is under the
protection of the Knight and now under
the protection of the bishop as well as
the Bishop from D7 Parks itself on E6
and Hikaru does have a pretty solid
position but it seems like black is
slightly better here Carlson has better
control of the center well coordinated
pieces and now a space advantage on the
king side as he pushes the H5 the H Pawn
up to H5 and grabs important squares on
the king side and potentially threatens
to banish the bishop with H5 H4 but
Carlson doesn't have to rush with that
move and he can expand even further if
he wants by playing G7 G5 and instead he
expands in a different way by
maneuvering the Knight first to F5 and
chasing the bishop over to H2 and now
the Knight Parks itself in the center
Knight F5 to D6 controlling important
light squares in the center E4 and C4
but Hikaru he is not resting either
Bishop F3 and now Knight B3 and Carlson
might have missed that move G5 was kind
of an autopilot reaction and Knight B3
is a nasty one because it attacks the
Deep 5 Pawn which is now hanging and the
C5 Bishop is also Under Fire and Carlson
is lucky that he has the move Knight E4
in order to cut the influence of the
white bishop and now a bunch of traits
could happen we could get a quick draw
here but I'm worried about hikaru's
Bishop on H2 which is biting on granite
and indeed we have a trade on C5 and
Hikaru now possesses the bishop pair but
will he also take on e4 no instead he
plays C4 and an excellent move by
Nakamura undermining the pawn on D5
which is fulfilling the important duty
of protecting the Knight on e4 which is
why D takes C4 or Rook takes E4 both
impossible because it would drop a minor
piece on e4 Carlson has to find a way
here to protect the pawn on D5 but
what's crazy is that Rook H to C8 runs
into c65 anyway and the bishop on E6
would be hanging with Jack and Hikaru
would get two Bishops for a rook which
is usually an overwhelming material
advantage as Carlson drops below a
minute he has dug himself into a bit of
a hole here missing that move Knight B3
and Hikaru not letting him breathe this
last move C3 C4 causing major problems
for black in the center and Carlson
might have to give away a pawn here one
way or the other really uncomfortable
there Magnus is frustrated at himself
for letting this happen he was better
out of the opening but allowing this
move Knight B3 and he's down to 30
seconds counter-striking with G4 and
we're getting a lot of Trades here
Hikaru takes on D5 and Hikaru likely
going to go up a pawn Here pawn takes E6
check is going to happen then he will
recapture the pawn on F3 and he will be
up upon in that end game but the biggest
Advantage here for Magnus is that
White's Bishop on H2 is still completely
out of the game so as long as Carlson
can keep that Bishop out of the game he
will have some practical compensation
for hikaru's extra Pawn no question that
the game has turned in White's favor
both on the board and also on the clock
Hikaru has a 20 second time Advantage
but an excellent retreating move by
Carlson as he re-establishes material
equality Knight G5
it forked the pawns on F3 and H3 but
look at Hikaru he says you're going to
H3 I'm going to close The Mousetrap with
F4 now the bishop on H2 finally has a
clear job the Knight on H3 is completely
trapped it has no way out because the G5
square is now protected by White's Pawn
but there is also no easy way to attack
the Knight on H3 so it's stuck kind of
like in a Norwegian prison but man
Hikaru is saying you can't attack the
Knight take that King F1 trying to get
to G2 Magnus Cuts him off tempo for
Tempo Rook h8 to G8 covering the G2
square and Hikaru brings his own Rook up
to C5 exploiting the drawback of Black's
previous move which is that the H Pawn
was left unsupervised but F5 cuts off
the fifth rank Carlson trying to
stabilize the situation in the center
and ikaro his Rook continues to run amok
rookie five check and Bishop G3 an
excellent move making possible the king
move up to G2 which would attack the
knight and king G2 here is still
possible Magnus would have to respond
with H4 counter-attacking the Bishop on
G3 and after all is said and done white
would go up upon and upon in a rook end
game but Hikaru he seems a little bit
confused you're trying to squeeze more
than that out of the position as he goes
rookie he wants to win the night in its
entirely in in its entirety he does not
want to give his Bishop away he does not
want to go a rook upon up in a rook end
game he wants to go a minor piece up in
this position and now H4 will be met
with Bishop H2 and black snipe is still
stranded and that is exactly what
happens and Carlson might have to
sacrifice his Knight eventually for the
F2 Pawn Hikaru with 15 seconds and
Carlson down to his last five and Hikaru
is attacking the queen side pawns giving
a check on B7 driving blacks King up to
G6 Rook B6 check for King The King and
the A6 Pawn but Carlson I feel like he's
setting something up on the king side a
little bit of hesitation from Hikaru he
can play Rook F6 but instead he captures
the pawn on A6 Carlson brings his Rook
back to G7 and King G4 King G4 is now a
big threat the King was threatening to
infiltrate to F3 and there it is the
Knight sacrifice on F2 and White's
Bishop is in big trouble Magnus
Carlson's Rook activates itself and
takes on B2 and Hikaru is also is up a
piece right now but look at the activity
of Black's pieces there is a past H Pawn
on H4 Black's Rook on B2 ideally placed
Hikaru seems nervous he checks on G6 and
recaptures the pawn on H4 but Carlson
has driven him to the back ranks and
King takes E3 the pawn on F4 is also
hanging and Carlson he doesn't capture
it yet instead he plays King F3 and he
is threatening to play E3 and E2 and win
the game Hikaru seems to be on the
defensive at this point firmly on the
defensive even though he is up a minor
piece and Carlson he is not touching
that pawn on F4 using it as an umbrella
that pawn on F4 is helping black and
with his last second Hikaru ties himself
to the F5 Pawn Carlson opens up a second
front and pushes B4 and ties his Rook
over to the 8-2 pawn Hikaru has to
remain on the second rank the players
blitzing out the move sikaru down to his
last eight seconds and keeping his Rook
on the second rank Carlson finally
captures the pawn on F4 and creates for
himself connected passers in the the
center and when will he push them he's
pushed F4 he's gotten his King to F3
Carlson on the cusp of winning this game
down a minor piece Hikaru checks him on
H3 and drives the king back to H4 back
to E4 Now The Rook Parks itself on H4 in
order to pin the F4 pawn and he attacks
it with his Bishop using some tactics
but the pawn was Untouchable there was a
mate on B1 and Carlson simply takes on
A2 he's up three pawns now for the minor
piece and the b-pawn is going to likely
win the game and B3 pushing that pawn
forward Hikaru has to put his Rook
behind the pawn and the pawn goes up to
B2 and white can't move his Bishop he
can't move his Bishop because of Rook A1
check and Hikaru is paralyzed he is in
zugs one and he is losing he cannot move
his King up to E2 either because the
pawn will promote with a discover check
and on his last seconds he car trying
one last attempt checking the black king
Carlson has garnered 30 seconds for
himself with the quickness of his play
and the King's zigzag skillfully away
from the check how adroitly Carlson
handles his rook and his King and F3 is
the hammer blow all of his once
threatening to promote he plays F2
Hikaru gives away his bishop and rookie
one check is Unstoppable what a win what
a turnaround in this game by Carlson and
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
click the link in the playlist for more
of these Blitz videos thank you so much
for watching
thank you